hoy vamos a ver cómo las sumas repetidas
nos llevan a la multiplicación cuando
multiplicamos podemos abreviar la
repetición de un número el signo de la
multiplicación que es como una equis
significa cuántas veces se repite el
número por ejemplo dos más dos más dos
más dos más dos más dos
lo podemos traducir en sumar seis veces
el número dos y seis por dos es igual a
12 ves qué sencillo probemos con otro
ejemplo tenemos 55 más 5 cómo lo podemos
simplificar son 35 por lo tanto hay que
sumar 3 veces 5 y el producto es 15
practiquemos una vez más hay una gata en
el edificio y tuvo cuatro gatitos
cuántas orejas de gatitos hay veamos
cada gatito tiene dos orejas y son
cuatro gatitos entonces tenemos que
sumar cuatro veces el número dos hay
ocho orejas de gatitos ahora pongamos de
un poquito más de dificultad tenemos la
siguiente suma
66 26 22
como crees que podamos resolverlo pausa
el vídeo e inténtalo no te olvides de
reproducir el vídeo de nuevo para saber
si llega hasta el resultado tenemos 3
veces el número 6 que lo podemos
traducir como 3 por 6 te fijas que aquí
estamos repasando las tablas de
multiplicar interesante no crees sigamos
después tenemos 3 veces el número 2 que
es lo mismo que 3 por 2 entonces cuánto
es
3 x 6 es igual a 18 y 3 por 2 es igual a
6 sumamos 18 + 6 y el resultado es 24
por último metemos a nuestro cerebro con
la siguiente operación
9 47 más 89 más 9 más
87 separemos la operación de la
siguiente forma tres veces 92 veces 82
veces 7 y una vez 4 esto también es lo
mismo que 9 por 3 8 por 2 7 por 2 y 4
por 1 lo notaste cuál será el resultado
resolvamos cada una de las
multiplicaciones por separado tres por
nueve o nueve por 33 27
2 por 8 8 por 23 16
2 por 77 por 2 es 14 1 por 4 o 4 por 1
es 4 ahora sumamos esos resultados y nos
da un total de 61 si resolvemos cada
multiplicación y al final sumamos esos
resultados tenemos más fácilmente que la
suma inicial nos da 61
recuerda que si tienes el mismo número
varias veces en la misma suma puedes
hacerla más simple usando una
multiplicación